at the World Economic Forum on Latin
America we set up the Davos debates
video room and invite the president's
dignitaries and business leaders in
attendance to stop by and respond via
video to your questions and ideas about
the region's most pressing challenges so
what are the challenges and
opportunities for Latin America in the
next 10 years pose your idea or question
in video or text and submit it at
youtube.com slash Davos you can vote on
your favorite submissions from others
too we'll put the top voted submissions
to the leaders in Carter henna Columbia
when they come to the Davos debates poof
giving you direct access to some of the
most powerful and influential people in
the world go to youtube.com slash Davos
today to join the conversation